الصمت هنا مختلف ليس كاي صمت حتى انه عرف
بصمت الموت فعلى طريق النجاه ينادي
المنقذون بصوت واحد ثم يصمتون جميعا
وسيله استخدمها المنقذون للعثور على
ناجيين في سوريا وعلى قله الامكانيات ولو
كان الامل ضعيفا بوجود انفاس تحت هذه
الانقاض يحاول عمال البحث بطرق بدائيه
وتقليديه
في ظل تعقيد البحث وصعوبه الوصول وسماع
الناجين تحت اقوام الركام تطورت ادوات
البحث لنجده العالقيين فاعتمد الخبراء على
تقنيات تكنولوجيه تطورت عبر الزمن ومن
ابرزها الفئران والصراصير المزوده
بكاميرات صغيره القادره على الدخول الى
امكنه لا يمكن رؤيتها او حتى سماع اصوات
تطلب استغاثه الافعى الروبوت على شكل
ثعبان يستطيع صعود درجات عاليه والتنقل
عبر المساحات الضيقه تقنيه حديثه يسعى
الباحثون لاستخدامها الطائرات المسيره
بامكانها فصل الاحياء عن الاموات عن طريق
الكشف عن حركه بسيطه للضحايا وحده فايندر
تاتي بحجم حقيبه اليد ترسل موجات دقيقه
منخفضه الطاقه ويمكن ان تكشف الموجات عن
خفيه مثل النبض الخفيف للجلد الذي يكشف عن
دقات القلب
مشعلا مصباحه ينادي مسابقا الزمن
صوته ينجح في انقاذ عالق من قبضه تلك
الانقاض بشتى الطرق وباي طريقه كانت يحاول
ولا يزال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه